what's what's up guys my name's Chris
and I'm a video producer out here in New
York today I'm gonna find my coworkers
some pizza for lunch
but we're not talking about regular
pizza we're not talking about your
boring toppings like pepperoni and
mushroom at all that lame [ __ ] we're
actually looking for a pizza that has
smaller pizzas on top of a pizza topped
with pizza which is insane for us
wearing the sweet hell are you gonna
find something like that
we're heading to Vinny's pizzeria in
Brooklyn
ladies and gentlemen we found it is in
the oven right now and I can't wait to
see this all right guys we've got the
goods right there let's head back to the
office pizza is amazing he says so
[ __ ] guys it's just like my go-to I
feel like I get a lot of [ __ ] because I
like mushrooms on my pizza and see you
later bangs when someone else is paying
I feel like it's gonna be something that
is a weird topping I'm still nervous I
don't know what this is gonna be I'm
pretty sure you're gonna give us a pizza
with like a shoe and like a pickle
[Music]
oh snap
it's people in it little babies this is
adorable I feel like this is gonna taste
like all my childhood dreams come true
do you eat them just all together you
get it together it just has more of it
on top can you pee on it you just have
to use like your whole hand like this
I would never fold this because it's
just so beautiful I don't want to like
smush them together I'm sorry to eat
your sister I'm gonna eat this whole
goddamn thing this is so good I'm
savoring I want to kill this I like your
mind if I saw it on the street I would
pick it up and eat it one in one thirds
pizza so it's 33% better than regular
pizza it's math it's pizza math is there
more that we can eat or is this it I'd
like